the only suspect in the kidnapping of 13
year old Jamie cloths is scheduled to
make his first court appearance today in
northern Wisconsin Jamie is now home
with her family she managed to escape on
Thursday with help from a woman walking
her dog we'll hear from that good
samaritan in our next half-hour Jake
Thomas Patterson is accused of abducting
Jamie and murdering her parents at their
home that was last October authorities
say he had no apparent connection to the
family before the killings now this
video shows parts of the living room at
of Patterson's home with scattered books
in a small Christmas tree gayle king is
there reporting in Barron Wisconsin
Jamie's hometown where she spoke to
three of her relatives about the moment
they learned
she'd been rescued it is their first
television interview since they were
reunited with Jamie Gale good morning
good morning nor as you can imagine we
were so excited to talk to them
yesterday it really was a very exciting
conversation for all of us who got to
meet the Claus family but I want to set
the scene first of where we are we are
in the lobby of the Justice Center and I
want to give you an idea about what
happens here 50 feet to my right is a
dispatch center that's where the 911
wall the 911 call came in the night that
Jamie Jamie's parents were shot and
killed fifty feet to my left is the jail
that is where Jake Patterson is sitting
in a Cell all alone and right above me
is a courtroom where he will make an
appearance later today so I say all this
to say a lot happens in this building
and this is a big day for Jake Patterson
but he is not the topic of conversation
today it is still about Jamie Claus as a
matter of fact they have a hashtag that
they say hashtag Jame Z I like that
Jamie Clauses family members say they
never gave up hope that she would be
found but like the rest of the country
they are really still in shock and only
on CBS this morning Clauses cousin
that's Lindsey Smith in two of her aunts
aunt Sousou Allard and Lynn cloths
describe how they're helping this little
13 year old girl heal by giving her all
the love she needs she's getting a lot
of love they also told us about what
it's like to finally have her home I
have to pinch myself
I woke up this morning and it's finally
like I don't have that pit in the bottom
of my stomach anymore it's such an
overwhelming amazing happy ending to
such a horrible beginning I still feel a
little in shock I just want to go over
there every day to my mom's house and
see Jamie yeah amazing to see your home
yeah because your mom is a legal
guardian now Jamie's your cousin yep
sort of now like a sister to you yep my
little sister I actually told my mom my
mom is secure all this no and my mom has
her heart has been just broken since
Jamie was gone and now I told her I said
I'd get my mom back you are happy again
you are it's just the best thing I've
ever seen
tell us how she's doing guys and how
you're how you're handling and preparing
her how is she doing right now on that
first step is surrounding her by law
making sure she's safe she feels safe
she's she's she's done pretty well gee I
wish I spent the afternoon there
yesterday we had her smile and laughing
going through things in her room how
will you go about getting the answers to
all of the questions that so many people
have and yourself included in due time
we have to take little steps
Jamie when she's ready to talk she will
nobody in the family is asking her how
what happened you know all of the
experts say you have to let them talk
yes but I just wonder his family members
know there would be so much that I would
want and I know you just want to know
but you know they're saying just let it
come up if she wants to be happy let her
be happy if she wants to be sad let her
be said she wants to be silly let her be
silly you know we got to let her let her
call the shots right now know is how you
each heard that you the news that she
was okay my dad had to call my neighbor
and she comes screaming in my door I'll
never ever forget her screaming sue sue
they found Jamie are you all surprised
by the strength because we keep hearing
her described as shy and quiet I am I'm
you are I am
the thing I want to wanted to express to
her immediately and we all do is the
pride we have in her for doing this
forgetting out for making it for the
power that she has you know I mean that
she took the power away from this man
that she did this I mean it's just
incredible
I mean lose strength that this little
girl has and the pride that we have in
her for it
that's instantly what I thought I think
there was the power of God behind it all
these people in this whole nation the
prayers that were said you know they're
grown people I think that would have
been paralyzed in fear here yes yes we
don't know what she went through but to
survive it and to get out of it and to
beat him in his own game and just
survive and get out of there I mean wow
wow we are all saying WOW about Jamie
Klaus and now that she's safe with her
loved ones the family says that they can
all begin the process of grieving for
Jamie's parents James and Denise they
said they sort of put that on the back
burner they haven't had a chance to
really digest that yet we'll have more
of our interview in our next hour
including why they will appear at the
suspects court appearance a little bit
later on today